I'm honored to be here because I really
think that the west coast of the US
meeting entrepreneurship is the absolute
future of this country I don't think it
is Washington I don't think it's
anything that's happening on the East
Coast I don't think we should care if
there is a bailout I don't think we
should care if there is a stimulus I
don't think we should care whatever
happens there because the technology
innovation curve always goes on not
world war one not the Great Depression
not world war two nothing that
politicians have ever done has changed
and stopped it it always goes on and it
increases exponentially and when
technology explosion meets
entrepreneurship then you create
wonderful new things and the speed of
technology innovation is actually
accelerating more and more so you know
what took Bill Gates you know 20 years
to build the Google guys did in ten
years and it goes faster and faster and
faster that means that you know a place
that rewards creativity and
entrepreneurship like the west coast of
the u.s. from LA to Silicon Valley to
Seattle is the absolute place to be it's
the place that is too resistant against
any form of depression or anything
that's going on as long as this
entrepreneurial spirit survives so the
first thing you have to do to be
successful is to be invited here and not
just just kidding I think it's the other
way around
so you have to do something and then
they invite you so in our case we
started a revolutionary company in the
video game space people would think you
know video games what's new they are
what what can you do what can you
revolutionize that's already a new
industry and the cool industry industry
and it turns out that it's actually a
possible to disrupt and change the video
games industry in a very very dramatic
dramatic way and so since we started
Tryon few years ago we have now raised
over a hundred million dollars in
initial financing at the last half of
2008 we raised the second largest
venture capital round in the world and
that the largest valuation of a
pre-revenue company
in history so Silicon Valley have seen a
lot of crazy things but in this case we
are unique so I want to talk about a
little bit of what we did to get to that
position and I want to do it in very
broad strokes so that everybody can take
something home from this so the first
thing is observation so sit back and
look at the industries every any
industry that interests you it doesn't
matter because every industry out there
is affected by this accelerate
accelerating innovation curve every
single industry out there therefore has
pain and a lot of pain and so I mean you
can you can clearly see the pain in this
picture I don't know if you can see this
you know clearly but the guys that are
hanging down there on the right those
are the New York Times
those are Time Warner those are
universal music those are literally
everybody in this world Verizon AT&T
literally everybody in entertainment
media and communications this entire
multi trillion-dollar market is going
downhill there is not one segment of the
global entertainment media and
communications industry that has a
combination of high growth rates and
high margins they are all affected
they're all hanging there and every
single linear format if you had started
five years ago to shorten every single
media company on the planet and you had
done it with leverage you'd be
incredibly rich right now so and that
already happened before the recession
and of course the recession is speeding
this up like if you have no idea so the
first thing if you want to start your
own company is observe where the pain is
take an industry that you're passionate
about and pick a big one and if you find
the pain there is the opportunity and
then actually analyze and find more pain
because there is even in areas that
people saw a very
cool and strong that is even more pain
so all these skeletons on the left there
are most of the big video games
companies Midway idols THQ you name them
even Electronic Arts is very very close
to hanging there so even this segment of
the entertainment and media industry
that people saw it was robust and great
and strong is affected and is in pain so
that is a huge industry in itself and it
is in pain and if you look at the market
leader like Electronic Arts in an in an
industry that still has top-line growth
their bottom line is collapsing why
because they have all these problems
rising up front development cost the
only thing that's going faster in the
video games industry today
is that then revenue is the development
cost which means their margins are
eroding despite the fact that the
industry is still growing
they have only limited social
connectivity in their current generation
of video games if you play a video game
today you can go online if you have an
xbox or ps3 you can play with a few
people but it's only peer-to-peer
connectivity you can have massively
social environments and because that's
the case you also have very limited
business models you can essentially only
sell your game and that's it and then
you have all these suckers you have the
platform providers they take 25% of your
top line you have the retailers that
take 25% of your top line you have the
pirates worldwide that are exploding and
you have the use markets that are
killing the space so you see that this
you know very doom a gloomy picture is
actually you know pretty accurately
representing almost every single aspect
of a multi trillion-dollar industry and
that means there must be dramatic
opportunity and you just have to find it
and even in this picture there is some
light there and it's up there in the
clouds
so and in this case actually in the
truest sense um it is in the clouds and
it is actually in cloud computing so if
you look at the drivers for this
dramatic pane almost all of them have to
do with broadband broadband allows
piracy broadband allows new business
models broadband allows for massively
social alternative offerings broadband
is driving people away from linear
formats and it is quickly becoming on a
global scale
the largest media entertainment and
communications platform in history it is
much bigger than cable much bigger than
broadcast television much bigger than
movies have been and the moment that
people shift from dial-up internet where
they have to pay by the minute or free
up their phone line to broadband they
start to hang out and is becoming this
giant entertainment and media platform
and the big franchises the big networks
the big if you want hit shows for the
broadband era have not been created you
only see emerging franchises and if you
think about the time when cable started
the first thing that people did was to
put NBC and ABC on cable and they called
this original cable programming they
only used cable for new distribution but
then other people much smarter people
said wait a minute you can actually use
cable for original programming you can
narrow cast you can charge everything
that was created innovative in
television in the last 25 years was
original cable programming from HBO to
MTV to CNN to ESPN and the broadcast
companies couldn't get it and those
giant franchises for the connected era
have not been created there are attempts
there is you know Club Penguin there is
world of warcraft
there are certain initial sinks but
there there are no general large
established networks franchises for
broadband entertainment out there but
even those initial franchises already
show the massive potential
and I can give you an example that you
might only understand if you know the
video game space but there is this
online game called world of warcraft out
there it is one small category of video
games called rpgs role-playing games
right I have an avatar I run around I
kill monsters that's the game basically
essentially and I go on quest on the PC
the RPG category was a dying category
mostly because of piracy worldwide so
it's a small category to begin with and
it was going down because of piracy and
lessened as people were actually
interested in making games for their
platform along comes Blizzard a very
good game developer makes a very good
RPG role-playing game and brings it
online and adds server components and
multiplayer gameplay to it they are now
able to charge a subscription $15 a
month they are now able to prevent
piracy and they turned a dying video
games category into a 1.3 billion
dollars annuity business with 50% +
operating modules the largest individual
media franchise of all times and that's
an initial product for broadband
entertainment so the initial attempts
really show the potential here and there
is massive opportunity so you observe
you find the pain you really analyze
what causes the pain you find the
opportunity once you've found the
opportunity you articulate your vision
how are you going to exploit this
opportunity and in in the true sense of
the word disrupt the industry create a
giant business in this wide-open space
that the incumbents have opened up by
not being able to react to this
opportunity clearly in our case it is
nothing less than cloud entertainment
you know you all know this this kind of
buzz words you know cloud computing
which has so many meanings but what it
really means is that you create a
data-driven continuous development
process for four things you do and you
move
package good software to
software-as-a-service that constantly
evolves and gets better and people have
done this in other other categories of
services you know if you look at Google
they are doing this to Microsoft in a
way but you can absolutely do it to
entertainment and the only thing you
have to really think about is you know
when cable came and people created
original cable entertainment what was
different about it what was using the
unique capabilities of cable that
broadcast television could not use well
narrowcast for example you cannot narrow
cast you cannot have 24 hours music or
sports or reality on broadcast
television because you have to give
something to everybody you cannot charge
for it you can't have an HBO or stars
and so on now think about cloud
computing and broadband what does it
allow you to do and then bring it all
together and you have something that is
very very powerful so instead of
building video games in the old paradigm
or entertainment or movies where you
build everything up front and then you
ship it and then you let it you know
pirates you know steal it from you and
the use market you know resell it you
just build as you go build enough to get
out there collect data while people are
playing and consuming your entertainment
and then you make it better on a daily
basis and you use data you use other
people's creativity and you evolve the
content constantly if people get excited
about measuring the quality of
advertising big deal
how about measuring the quality of
content how about getting out there
faster saving money not building
everything up front and sticking it to
the pirates in the used market while you
do it and really learning from what
people want and why you do it why you do
it
let thousands of people play together
give them massive social connectivity
you can do it in a new cloud computing
server architectures that allow you
actually to have hundreds of thousands
of people play together and then you
know create business models that are
different don't just sell it create you
know recurring businesses subscriptions
in-game items sales you know vanity
items now that I'm playing with hundreds
of thousands of people buying stuff in
the
game is almost as meaningful than buying
a big car outside of the game because
all my friends are there and I can show
off once you have this connectivity you
can do all these wonderful things and
you can create terrific businesses and
remember you know world of warcraft from
a dying category the world's largest
individual entertainment and media
franchise of all times so the technology
and the way to fit this equation and
really create dog computing is to take
video games or any form of entertainment
and move it out of the client an
individual computer and individual
projector an individual console or game
game device and take the entire
computing out of that device and into
the network and when you do it you can
create cloud entertainment and the only
thing you need is connectivity and and
connectivity is good is growing like
crazy there's nothing growing as fast as
connectivity in this world right now so
once you have identified once you have
really articulated your vision then you
go about execute execution and because
you have a giant opportunity that you go
after the only thing you have to do now
is to take out risk the opportunity is
giant it's always there you go after it
you just have to address all the things
that could make you fail so it's you
know if you buy a business with big with
a lot of leverage and debt the only
thing you do is to pay down that as fast
as you can
you take out the risk and you do the
same here you buy a business basically
there is a giant opportunity you start
your business you go after a giant
opportunity and then you just take out
risk so the first thing you have to do
is to prove that you can build the
technology so start small build a
product type show that you can do it we
did this at the beginning of 2006 where
we raised our first venture capital
round very very quickly
typical Silicon Valley around we didn't
go and say we need 100 million dollars
we raised a small round and we proved it
out very quickly and after we proved it
out a year later
we then brought in three of the world's
top five media companies Time Warner NBC
Universal and Berlin's manuals biggest
media company they have incredible
assets they have everything from wanna
you know movie studios to Universal to
HBO to the sci-fi channel - Bravo - out
here in Europe - free mental media that
does all the American Idol shows so
terrific portfolio of assets amazing
partners and they also have pain and
they want to be in the new world so
about a year after we had our first
round we raised our second round and we
raised thirty million dollars just by
having a really good technology
prototype and we raised money now to
build applications on their platform
build franchises and and then we went
and signed up Talent literally across
the board we are based next to EA
here in Redwood City and we have a lot
of their best engineers artists
designers we are next to Sony online in
San Diego and we have a lot of their
best engineers designers artists and
we're next to NCsoft in Austin Texas and
we have more than a lot of their best
people and we also have started them to
work with external developers anything
that gets you to scale and you know in
the in the games world you have these
great setups of people across the world
that love to make great content but of
course cannot build a large scale you
know fully server based technology
architecture don't have the money don't
have the media partners don't have all
the things that you can bring and then
finally even another year later this
summer we raised our third round of
funding we raised another 70 million
dollars 7-0 and it was the second
largest VC round in the world in the
second quarter second half of 2008 and
and that is important because we really
don't want to build just one game and if
you build one game then your bet on
having a hit show what we want to be is
a network for in next generation for
broadband entertainment and the network
of course you know builds their own
shows and uses their own creativity but
also promote
and uses other people's creativity for
scale and for risk reduction and it's
all about the portfolio that you built
so in our case we build a tremendous
platform that is industry-leading and
revolutionary that allows you literally
to treat games or any form of
entertainment as cloud computing that we
can now scale by building applications
on top of it some we build in-house some
we build with external partners and and
so we scale and every single step by you
know raising more money hiring better
people
you know proving out the technology
getting the right partners on board and
even going from you know one hit driven
to you know portfolio Network we took
out risk so there is not one single
piece right now we believe that can sink
us and that is very very important
but of course there are some key
elements that never change no matter
what you do and what opportunity you go
after you really have to give it all I
mean don't become an entrepreneur if
you're not ready to work you know your
butts off and if you're not ready to
instill this you know passion and
obsession in your team so clearly you
know quality in this world where people
have everything they want and can get
everything they want is tremendously
important and you just have to look at
Nintendo or Apple and see how companies
that can build really high quality
products insanely good product are set
apart and in a way it's winner-takes-all
we can have a team of 100 people build a
product that a billion people can access
on broadband worldwide and if it's good
you will have an absolutely spectacular
success if it's if it's decent you still
have a good product but it's an order of
magnitude smaller and if it's bad it's
another order of magnitude so the the
obsession was you know taking the time
having us enough money focusing on the
right creative creative environment is
absolutely important and I would argue
not just for you know entertainment
media products consumer products
anything that you have to sell to people
anywhere in the world
you have to be obsessed with building
absolutely incredible product obsession
with people so particularly in this in
this environment right now you can hire
the best people even if you are a small
company if you have some money you can
get the best people and if you can
articulate your vision really clearly
and you can show how you disrupt a big
industry you can take the best people
out of the industry leaders and don't
compromise take the absolute best and
for me best means they are extremely
talented they have the right experience
and they also culturally fit with your
company with your vision and what you
want to do and if even one of those
three is is not top-notch then don't
hire that person and if you have already
hired a person that is not your play or
turns out to be then it's a perfect year
to replace that person with somebody
that is really triple-a I mean I would
argue that this is the best year in a
long long time to start a company
because of all these things the
technology innovation curve is exploding
traditional incumbents are all suffering
people want to get out there and if you
have a realistic alternative they follow
you and then of course you know be
obsessed with efficiency culture so if
you build something complicated you can
only do it as a team make sure that
everybody understands that they have to
make communication and teamwork in the
party and art they have to be their best
in terms of teamwork and communication
not just the best as individual
performers otherwise you will fail
because it is getting so complex but if
you all do this I think there is an
incredible opportunity out there to
build fantastic businesses and you know
from my perspective my great passion is
of course that everything would be
networked and I think you know we had
this giant IT revolution that was driven
by Moore's law and boy was that strong I
don't know if you know if you heard of
Moore's law most was the guy at Intel
that basically said chip capacity is
essentially doubling every 18 months
it's an exponential law and the
essentially means it for a long time you
feel and see nothing and then it takes
off dramatically and of course today a
cell phone has
more capacity than a supercomputer in
the 60s or 70s and that's Moore's law
and that's extremely powerful you can do
more with your smartphone today than the
world's biggest supercomputer could
thirty years ago
that's Moore's law but there is another
law and unfortunately not called
Butler's law it's called butters law
that was a guy at Bell Labs I believe
who said that fiber optics and
essentially broadband capacity doubles
every nine months now can you imagine
that if Moore's law has revolutionized
the world by doubling every 18 months
chip capacity if connectivity doubles
indeed every nine months there's going
to be the most insane transformation
that we will see in our lifetime and it
has started now you have critical mass
number of broadband anywhere in the
world now and if the backbones you know
double capacity so rapidly it not only
means that the network and the user is
connected at faster and faster speed it
also means that you can connect
computers to each other at faster and
faster speed so instead of building you
know one machine that does it all you
just stitch thousands hundreds of
thousands together and we are doing this
now on the server side it essentially
means you have unlimited computing power
because the computers can communicate
with unmeasurable speed and and so
everything will be connected everything
will be a service that's that's I think
becoming more and more clear and it
starts with entertainment and service
applications because that's so close to
data and you know jokingly we're going
to connect you know humans and the
network first and and in a way you have
the matrix they are you can argue that
these big virtual worlds are very close
to it you know you only have to really
get it straight into your brain and
you're done but you can also see you
know telematics basically that the
connection of machine and and network
taking off big time I mean the Army is
building you know giant networks to put
all that drones and robots on networks
you see it cars that are becoming
connected and was this explosion of
connectivity that
a huge new frontier and then finally
everything is connected humans machines
you know the network is really taking
over and it is creating fantastic
opportunities for entrepreneurs so find
the pain analyze the pain find your
opportunities articulate your vision
very very clearly then you will have no
problem attracting great people
attracting money even in today's
environment absolutely no problem you
can take them out of the back of the
biggest and best companies and then you
can have the biggest and best companies
finance you and then you can disrupt
them and and that's it basically and
don't give up if the environment doesn't
look so good because the technology
innovation curve is exponentially
growing and no world war and no great
depression has ever stopped it all right
so that's the the presentation and I'm
happy to take some questions
sure yeah right well you know you can
either be in the industry or you can
look at it from the sidelines or you can
you know you can meet people that you
that know the industry really well I
mean I think in this case it was very
obvious
I saw it actually before I went into the
game space when I was at have a business
called many many years ago I wrote a
paper with the guy called Clayton
Christensen he wrote the book the
innovators dilemma I don't know if
anybody of you know that book he was my
general management professor at Harvard
Business School great guy and the the
the paper was about this it was
basically saying you have all these
waves of disruption in entertainment and
media and broadband is going to be the
biggest disruptive force of all times in
entertainment and media and that is now
happening so I think once you know that
there is a big opportunity you have to
wait for the right time and get yourself
in place and you know you can get
yourself in place by
to a company that is a disrupter that is
going to be disrupted and somehow get
yourself in place I well before I
started Tryon I was the vice president
for global online at Electronic Arts but
I got to Electronic Arts because I felt
that this big disruption was coming and
I wanted to see if they can be a leader
if they would be a disrupter or they
would indeed be disrupted and you see
where I am now so I made my judgment
call so I think at the beginning the
incumbents have the best people that's
where they are right that's why you find
them that's why you find the people that
have that have great experience in the
space but the moment that the incumbents
get in trouble and growth slows down it
is it is becoming clear to the smartest
people that something new is coming and
that's when the incumbents become
vulnerable it will happen to us at some
points right I mean I hope I'm on my
boat in the Caribbean then but just
kidding so but that's when the
incumbents become vulnerable and when
the timing is right and you really hit
this this nerve of the industry then you
can actually go after the best people
and I personally think you know the best
are these combinations of people that
they not everybody is right for start-up
not everybody is right for the new
disruptive wave you have to find people
that you know have great talent that
have relevant experience and that share
your cultural mindset in many many cases
it's not the people that have been there
for 20 years or 25 years it's the people
that have been there for five to ten
years they have enough relevant
experience but they still hungry and
they also feel that you know their time
is coming that this last business cycle
the last 25 years was not their cycle
their cycle is coming
and and that's you know that's the
caliber of people that you want I mean
you you have to have like you know
everything in life you know have to know
people you have to speak to people you
have to communicate a lot and you have
to ask a lot of questions and if you
identify one good person I bet that they
can tell you you know the names and the
contact information of 20 more you know
just focus your entire energy and
finding one really good person go to
conferences I mean if you're in the
industry it's easy and if not then just
focus your energy on fun finding is one
really really good person make him your
business partner or making your first
employee and and go from there right
yeah so I mean we are growing quickly we
have now 180 people internally and we
also are working with external
developers at every single stage of
growth you introduce new risk right you
grow to build a portfolio to take out
risk to scale you get more money but of
course with growers you introduce new
risk because there are people that don't
have the skillset to manage bigger
companies there are processes that are
really great for 25 people but not for
150 and so you have to stay paranoid you
know across you know all the time and I
think you know growth is one of the
biggest risk I think to the organization
and you know we kind of I wouldn't say
we constantly restructure but we
constantly think about how we improve
the process how we improve how we adopt
the culture to being bigger without
losing the feeling of being you know
creative startup and I think that's
probably the biggest risk
[Music]
yeah so right now everything we do we do
behind closed doors so we have several
products in development but we don't
have an open playing session yet so we
still we already collecting information
we already have people playing but it's
very close to our chest so we're using
that as an advantage being able to
essentially get direct feedback
measuring content quality process
quality to improve the product and to
polish them no no well simply in a
simplified way you have to imagine that
your entire game world now is a database
that's it
so everything that people do creates a
database entry and of course that
shouldn't sound like Big Brother it's
it's you know we can we can mined data
in a more collective fashion so how many
people go to a certain area how many
people play a certain quest how many
people succeed to fast how many people
come back to something and so you can
actually mind a tremendous amount of
data and the learning curve is actually
to figure out what to look at if if
literally everything creates a data
entry then what is the relevant data and
you know if you can nail that it's a
huge advantage
[Music]
[Music]
yes yes I think that's absolutely
brilliant and that's one of the key
reasons why most software companies are
hit so hard by you know cloud computing
and software as-a-service the entire
culture the way that the teams are set
up is for you know betch production
essentially right you build it you ship
it you roll over to the next thing and
in that you know in a big way prevents
you from you know being very very
successful in the new world apart from
you also have to you know meet your you
know Wall Street expectations every
quarter you can't really take a lot of
good people and put them on building a
new technology platform and all those
other things so there are hurdles that
are you know technology-based that are
you know business pays and then there
are also lots of hurdles for incumbents
that are processing culture-based I
think it's absolutely true yeah great
question
well you built insanely good products I
think and then you you identify people
that you could attract as early adopters
and because it's massively social right
yeah well I think you know probably
again if you find ways so that you can
use peers to recruit their peers or
friends to recruit their friends I think
that's the biggest trust builder if you
have a few early adopters and they like
it and they speak out and if you find
ways where you can use connectivity not
only for the constant updating and
measuring but also for the social piece
and connect people they become your
evangelists they become your recruiting
force and and that makes it so
attractive word-of-mouth
you know reviews and then ideally you
have applications that that get better
if there are more people involved you
know I couldn't tell you right now for
accounting of how this would be but I'm
sure even for accounting you could find
ways of you know if I recruit other
people and we use the same tools
together we're more effective once you
can do that it spreads like wildfire
well see we didn't do it like you know
now we go out and raise a hundred
million dollars we did it small and then
larger and then larger and we proved
what we said we would do when we did it
every time during the way and I think if
you do it in that you know evolutionary
incremental way it's always doable and
you know you can always adjust to you
know the exact amount of what you'll be
able to raise and and so on there are I
think there are many many businesses
that you could start and even disruptive
businesses that you could start without
funding that you could you know very you
know start very very small and sign up
some customers get some revenue in and
then there are bigger bets you know that
you know are really right for venture
capital you know if you built this you
know giant you know and game franchises
you know they all black swans in a way
they could be giant and they could fail
so that's where really venture capital
plays best and so I think you should
always think you know really really hard
what what's the structure and for every
one we got different investor types and
the class of the investors got bigger
and bigger so that it always stayed is
small bet for them and and you know
being being very mindful of what you're
selling because if you build a company
and you go to investors then you're also
selling something you're selling a stake
in an opportunity in in in a technology
in a team and you have to find the right
buyer that that can handle that type of
risk and it's actually hungry for that
type of risk no no absolutely not
you can structure the deal also in a way
that they don't
[Music]
yeah I think we just keep you know very
selectively recruiting you know some
people I think we know pretty much
exactly what I mean there is you know
there are some your marketing skills
there's some web web 2.0 skills there
are some skills that are not typical in
the games industry but mostly we are
recruiting actually people that are that
have been in the industry for a long
time that have proven themselves and
that are this combination of you know
very very strong more talent relevant
experience and what we perceive as a
great cultural fit was what we try to do
[Music]
so one of each one technology lead one
design lead one art-lete so that you can
very rapidly prototype and in this case
you even prototype on paper first I mean
when we got started we had a design
document and the technology document
that was all but I couldn't have done
this on my own so you get the you know
you get it a tiny microcosm of what you
need you get those people first and and
then you can actually you know talk to
you know VCS and so on because then
you're prepared and you can basically
answer everything and you know we talked
about we took a few months of
preparation after we had kind of the
core team together really polished
everything but once we present it in a
few weeks we got it all closed and every
single time we went fundraising we did
it in a matter of weeks you know two or
three weeks every single time
through my co-founders who friend
friends in the industry talking oh I
think that's I mean Oh everybody's
opinion but we still don't have a VP of
HR when we have 180 people we had 150
people and raised over a hundred million
dollars before we had a CFO we had a
lady that did accounting HR and
operations and was also my admin for for
the first time and myself that was in
our entire corporate overhead to getting
to a hundred and fifty people and over a
hundred million dollars in revenue so
the only two people that didn't add any
value was Chee and I every everybody
else was in development and technology
and engineering there was absolutely no
overhead so I would say forget hiring in
an HR person you have to be the salesman
for everything you have to be the
salesman to the VCS to the media
companies to the employees anybody in
everybody and if you can cannot
articulate your vision so clear that
people just want to be there right away
and don't do it
yeah we good actually right now I would
say yeah so but we're still looking for
a great talent and so you know if you
know somebody that you think is
absolutely spectacular and and and what
fit with what we do we are always open
to that we're still hiring significantly
we hired about a hundred people in 2008
and we are still going to hire a very
significant number of people this year
one of the very few companies probably
that it's hiring you know very
aggressively far less than my value has
has appreciated so everything around my
resolution was much much and the team I
mean this is very very important you
don't want to end up in a situation
where the team has not enough stake in
the company that they're interested so
everybody at Tryon is an owner everybody
has talked options and we have still a
very very significant percentage of the
company in the hands of the team and the
way we got there is by staging our
fundraising taking a small amount first
and proving it taking a larger amount
and proving it taking a big amount and
proving it and fighting hard for getting
the right valuation you know I have
heard people saying that for a few
million dollars they had to give away
you know 50% 80% of whatever of the
company they should not be CEOs they
should not be running companies they
should not raising capital if they can't
defend the equity stake of their teams
better they shouldn't be doing it so I
think everything in life depends how
well can you articulate how well can you
stage it how well can you find the
people that have a particular
for this industry for this risk and then
you get deals that make sense for them
and make sense for the team right so I I
don't believe in absolutes and for the
right opportunity VCS are absolutely
fantastic you know we started out with
trinity ventures and DCM here in Silicon
Valley to blue-chip these seeds and they
have been absolutely outstanding
partners for us and then we added an
la-based VC rusty Canyon and then we got
the media companies and then finally we
went even bigger and got you know huge
you know capital market funds to come in
in every single time we went to the
people that had the right appetizer the
right size and the right appetite for
this kind of risk okay yeah I mean yeah
don't do dumb deals that's you know
timing all right please
[Music]
the hardest part was actually that we
had to make room for all three we had
all three competing we only thought we
could accommodate two but I really
wanted all three so we had to go back to
our VCS and said you know you have to
make a little room so we can accommodate
all three of them so it doesn't have to
come out of the team's
pipe talking about good deals and so it
wasn't too hard actually I mean they go
to conferences they constantly looking
for opportunities and they're absolutely
looking for opportunities in those areas
that they see disrupting their core
businesses they want to be there they
just don't know how to so that I mean
I'm not joking in a way if I say the
same people that can provide employees
and opportunity to you can even employ
some of the money to you and get a stake
so it's it's not that just that you rip
them off you give them a stake in
something great that you build and you
also give them inside into markets that
they're really really interested in and
in some cases you can even partner so we
have one partnership with NBC Universal
that I think is really really
groundbreaking we're making a game and
one of their cable television networks
the sci-fi Network is making a
television show and why are we making
this huge game world they are telling a
character story in that game world and
the show and the game will launch
together and because the game is fully
dynamic the show in the game will
actually evolve together and the
president of sci-fi has been on record
in the LA times basically saying this is
the holy grail this is what you know you
have been dreaming off so you can I
think you can always go for you know
partnerships win wins and and with those
guys and then I don't think it's
difficult
me on cable over broadband oh yeah no I
of course I mean one of the things that
brought that allows you to do is to
narrow cast to an extreme never seen
before right and since you do it
globally you have these interest in
affinity groups that are even larger
than the US market potentially and you
can definitely narrowcast much more than
cable you can also charge better it's
not just subscriptions you can sell
people items or stuff retail products
but it's not the only thing you can do
on broadband and I think that is very
important if you're just thinking of
making more shows for more and more
narrowly defined demographics I think
that's missing the point because
broadband is an interactive platform
that not only allows you now to narrow
cast even more but it allows you to jump
in and change the outcome and really
influence what's going on so every
linear format is not using this power of
broadband for example the other big
power problem is that you can do things
together with your friends and even if
you don't want to do them together with
your friends you can show off to your
friends and so community and vanity are
you know huge on broadband is you know
and pure linear formats that are just
more narrow are not leveraging that the
these other performance characteristics
of broadband there are tremendous
[Music]
yes that's in that's attractive and you
can see I mean you can see Facebook you
can see YouTube everybody wants to
become more game-like they're adding
game features they're you know they're
talking publicly how important that is
because they're interactive platforms
and just you know linear or just people
talking to each other is not sticky
enough it's not monetizable enough so
everybody tries to get more game-like
because that's today the most proven
form of interactivity really in in the
entertainment media space yeah so a very
established and proven model of
subscriptions and that's a great model
you know my professor have a Business
School always in for entrepreneurial
finance used to joke look at downtown
all the big tallest buildings are new
ative businesses they insurance
companies the cable companies they're
all kinds of companies that have figured
out how to get money on a regular basis
so that's terrific the other great model
is because you're connected and because
you there with all your friends to sell
items to sell items that help you
succeed more to sell items that make you
look better and people are buying them
like crazy and you know if you are in
this game world for 20 or 40 hours a
week and all your friends are there
believe me
the status you have in that world
becomes as important to you in many
cases more important than the status you
have in the real world and stuff that
enhance your status in that virtual
world are valuable to you and that's the
social connectivity that gives you that
extra monitor monetization power there's
people in Scandinavia where social you
know welfare is really high they can't
get enough to live off welfare and they
don't go to work anymore even if they
could because they get all their status
the other reason why we go to work
from the social interaction in virtual
worlds so if you can for $15 a month be
a hero have this you know kick ass horse
you know giant sword you know all your
friends are there and everybody sings
you extremely cool and why bother with
the real world all right so you know
what I'm talking about I'm German and
Swedish so I can I can talk them so all
right well the vision is that you can
create an entertainment and media
network for the broadband era that is as
disruptive and powerful as you know HBO
and CNN and MTV and all these have been
in the cable era or then NBC and ABC
have been to the movie business that we
are in this giant new disruption and
that a successful business in the new
world has to incorporate all the
strengths of the broadband platform has
to be massively social has to be
constantly evolving has to be as it has
to be a service as we cloud computing so
it and you know in another way of saying
it is 30 years of growth in the games
business have been games it's packaged
good software that's over the next 30
years
our games as a service simulated in
giant on giant server platforms with
connectivity exploding with so much
better performance critics better
business models better margins better
growth better everything and that the
incumbents are not able to get there
because incumbents have never been able
to get there in history Microsoft could
not be Google that the movie studios
could not be the television companies
the television companies could not be
the cable companies the more immediate
linear companies could not be the games
companies and none of them can be the
broadband entertainment companies of
tomorrow it's a natural law
you know Microsoft has the Xbox Live
yeah so there's yeah it's a great great
thirty billion dollar yeah well they are
they are - what we do what Comcast is -
MTV and HBO they are one of the
distributors so if you have an Xbox and
you're an Xbox Live customer then you
were the equivalent of being a Comcast
customer and we give you content we give
you HBO and CNN and MTV I met the CFO of
Comcast or actually one of their
founders Julian broadsky years ago and
he said you know when we started Comcast
we had you know we aggregated all these
people and the only reason why we
succeeded at the end is because much
smarter people than we are created all
these great content assets and we could
just sit back and collect money and they
started HBO and they started CNN and
they started MTV and so Xbox and Xbox
Live is great but it's nothing with our
content and applications so we're
building the technology platform that
allows you to build the content
applications so the server based
platform that allows you to basically
create and run and publish games of the
quality of a Halo or world of warcraft
the madden but was the entire simulation
done server-side in the cloud you can
update them change them evolve them have
them massively social and we can now use
the Xbox we can use the ps3 we can use
any connected computer out there as an
access device the real platform is now
broadband plus the servers what has been
a platform traditionally the Xbox the
ps3 they are just access terminals now
they they are for rendering an input and
output so they're great partners
anybody who creates a device that's
connected to broadband and anybody who
creates more broadband speed around the
world is our partner it's all upside for
us the good thing is though we don't
they are not gatekeepers in the way that
cable is the gatekeeper the
cause you have the Xbox you have the ps3
you have the Nintendo
you also have PC and direct-to-consumer
where you can always go and so it's a
much more open world in an IP driven
environment well yeah I mean yeah of
course I mean you you you're not stupid
you don't for example render on a server
that doesn't in the games world doesn't
give you any advantage but you cannot
add today's broadband speed right you do
that locally there are certain things
that you use the local machines for and
every PC every Xbox every ps3 every we
helps you because they already have the
input/output device they have the
rendering capabilities so they're all
your partners but the key is we're not
just making peer-to-peer connectivity
and server and client based games that
are static the games can be updated
constantly and evolved and you can have
massively social environments and much
better business models
[Music]
yeah or other well I think every form of
entertainment that is very very engaging
has the risk that people spend too much
time on it and that they don't devote
enough time to other things that are
important in their life their families
their kids their job their you know
physical health their friends and so on
at least in online massively multiplayer
games you have the social component so
at least you meet with your friends you
do things in a social environment and in
my mind that's significantly better than
just sitting there playing on your own
and but you know whenever it's really
really engaging people can't spend too
much time I mean there are people in
Asia that you know have been playing for
you know 24 hours straight or 48 hours
straight and then die in front of their
PC it has happened of course kids die
playing in the streets right I mean
every I mean everything has risks so you
know we try not to do anything that is
introducing too much violence that is
not you know ethical there is not you
know
appropriate for the particular
demographics that we're looking at but
the one thing you have to remember if
book if books we're new today a new form
of entertainment what would people say
they would say that solitaire they're
violent they would keep you away from
your friends you know that and then
don't even have good graphics and nobody
would understand why you would read that
thing right so in a way every form of
entertainment that's new has always
faced those this is the worst thing ever
that happened to radio they happen to
television to movies to traditional
video games to online multiplayer games
everything that people don't understand
or that they have not been around wears
when they were young they consider worse
and I'm not saying they are not bad
things there but they consider worse
than everything else and it always
becomes this absolute very quickly it's
responsible for everything bad in the
world that's also risk yeah well we we
need a continuous inflow of great and
talented people we need to be able to
provide them an environment that they
really like or they feel they can be
creative where they have the time to
polish what they do and and then you
know I believe it creates a very strong
positive feedback loop but we have to
stay vigilant I mean we could be
disrupted by somebody else very quickly
and yeah I think it goes faster and
faster if you had 20 years in the past
to build you know your big business and
then somebody else came after you you
had you know 10 years maybe you only
have five years no you know it you can
really see it you can sense it how this
you know technology curve is
accelerating more and more and more all
right thank you very much for your time
I really appreciate
you
you